hall-of-famer Turner Sports NBA analyst
Reggie Miller on the call for the
Rockets and the Jazz that'll be Thursday
night at 10:30 Eastern alongside Kevin
Harlan on TNT red joins us now hey reg
how are you good morning now did the
Urban Meyer retirement I'm sure that
caught a lot of people off-guard that
came from out of left field but are we
are we really surprised
I think the suspension at the beginning
of the year could have been somewhat the
writing on the wall
his involvement or lack of involvement
and what he knew that was going on in
his program I think a lot of that
probably helped kind of push him out the
door I'm sure people behind closed doors
are going to say this is probably a
horst pushed retirement really I hope
not
I think he's deserved and earned the
right to retire but we do know he's a
he's a family man and he's had somewhat
of health problems
yeah is that what the first retirement
was somewhat about so maybe something
came back I hope that's the case but I
think it caught it caught a lot of
people off-guard this morning I think
what caught me off-guard is I just
spilled my water all over the desk here
reg so I apologize can you get Seaton
can you bring me over her paper to hold
on its line well you know I never really
did have the best of you know I've seen
a few clips that you coming off screen
and butterfingers was kind of the
catchphrase people started to use a
little bit but Wow no I'm only playing
I'm only playing my nickname was golden
boy reg not butterfingers
right yeah it was golden boy but it was
a negative it was a negative my college
coach would call me golden boy he never
called me by my name he called me golden
boy and it was not men in a positive way
well what made it so negative then are
you gonna explain why
the Golden Boy nickname is not so nice
for you I think he was mocking me that
maybe I thought I was better than what I
was and I was like the golden child the
golden boy and like imagine your coach
doesn't call you by your name ever he
never called me by my name and he didn't
let me play either in fact when I went
in to say that I was transferring he was
at his desk he didn't turn around he
just said okay
and I went okay so I'm like my dad goes
are you sure you want to transfer I go
yeah he goes well what's coach think I
go I didn't even turn around when I said
I was gonna transfer give me an idea of
just what he thought of my my career
okay I want to track down this coach you
please give us the day come on Bob
monkey I don't even know if he's still
alive I may have sent him to an early
grave but I don't even know if he
remembers me other than he called me
golden boy
by golly golden boy get out and he would
you know he would put me on the bench
yeah not good not good all right a
couple of things here I mentioned tre
young that we keep trying to put him in
shoehorn him in here is the next step
cur and then they played last night and
Steph Curry goes can we stop this can we
stop let him have his own identity he's
not me it's not fair to compare him to
me so what advice would you give tre
young because the numbers would Trey
young in Atlanta are not good at all reg
his shooting percentage and really is
court awareness is his suspect when it
comes to shooting he's just he can be a
great shooter but he's not taking great
shots correct and he has shown flashes
at times he has had some solid games but
if you look at the total body of work I
wouldn't say it's been a disappointment
I think it's more so growth let's not
forget now a rookie after his freshman
year at Oklahoma so he's 1920 and he's
he is smaller than what Steph was his
rookie
year so I think there's a lot of room
for him to grow well number one you had
Steph being a couple years older than
him too when he got into the league
correct correct correct
Steph stayed three years at Davidson and
this kid even though played fantastic
for the Sooners a season ago she still
the freshman so it's a boy playing
amongst men and I think that's showing
but I agree with death that would be
like the compare people comparing myself
to Jordans game no you can't do that
you're talking about a two-time MVP and
a generational type player in Steph
Curry and people like to make the
comparisons because there is a similar
size not the same size they both have
unlimited range those Steph is a little
bit more accurate so of course people
are always saying who's the next Jordan
the next one look they're gonna be
comparing Zion Williams to LeBron James
they're doing that now he's the next
LeBron James no he's now there's one
LeBron James there's one Steph Curry
there's one Zion Williams and obviously
there's one Trey young if I'm Trey I
need to work on my decision-making
I mean his decision-making is for the
point guard position is terrible that's
the one thing his shooting will come
yeah he puts too much time in the lab
I'm not worried about a shooting to me
his decision-making has to get much
better at Theodore Kobe Bryant says the
Lakers will be champs sooner and then
laughing at Warriors fans so sooner than
later what do you think Kobe means by
that
I mean we're adding a little more
pressure than LeBron but is like zing at
LeBron I don't I'm not quite sure about
sooner than later I could be wrong a lot
of pieces need to happen first
Parappa Lincoln Magic Johnson for that
to happen but if this Golden State team
if everyone resized Kady comes back clay
if either way to get you know dream on
on the same page with everyone
I see this run continuing so uh sooner
there later defines her Kobayashi but I
think this is the Lakers mystique
talking versus the reality speaking I
thought it was interesting though like
you know I think that everybody he's
rooting for the Lakers to do well
because he's probably rooting for Jeanie
buss you know to do well taking over
that team but I wonder if he really
feels like sooner they're they're gonna
be champs sooner than later
and what does sooner mean with LeBron
James is this a 2o years you Rolla you
rile up your fan base which is good they
have been playing well as of late but
sooner or later to me sooner is like you
said within two years they're not
winning a championship within two years
unless Kawhi comes unless KT comes next
year and then I could possibly see that
two to three years I don't see a
championship so maybe later than sooner
five years down the rabbit LeBron will
be nearing 40 then so I don't see it
then I look it's a move to rile the fan
base the Warriors have dominated the
league over the last five to six years
the buzz is for Golden State there's a
sexy team they created they changed the
rules in the landscape of claim small
every team now has to have a draymond
Green that can switch and play point
guards and shooting guards so they have
that death lineup with Andre Iguodala
and they go small and everyone has
attested to that so in a sense there are
outliers because they stand out and they
do these things and you know they're the
team and I think Kobe is trying to rein
it back and rile up the fan base and get
people back on the Lakers bandwagon
talking to Reggie Miller reg has the
Rockets and the Jazz coming up Thursday
night 10:30 Eastern on TNT along with
Kevin Harlan how many had coaches did
you have in the NBA
Wow 10 plus dr. Jack Ramsay obviously
Larry Bird Rick Carlisle Larry Brown
George Irvine Bell Daniels for a weekend
dick for say how much say did you have
later in your career recently I bring
this up is Aaron Rodgers at 35 they're
gonna bring in a new head coach and he
says he's not there the Packers say he's
not involved in this process here were
you consulted at any point in your
career zero absolutely zero and
especially during my heyday of my first
eight years you would think I would have
been dolly walks told me nothing he
would get he wouldn't give me a heads up
on anything I'm player personnel on
Coach hirings nothing didn't tell me
anything I didn't make the team better
you know we need some veterans we need
some shooter did you want to be involved
hey it's given the opportunity I mean it
would have been nice but I trusted
Donnie and that's the kind of
relationship you've got to have with
your front office I hope Aaron Rodgers
trusts his front office I hope he trusts
the President or GM to make the right
decision but no I had zero idea of when
they were gonna know you would hear buzz
that you know Larry legends get ready to
be your coach or Isiah you know there
was another coach of ours
you would hear things but I wouldn't
call Donnie up and say don't do this or
hire this person nor that he ever ever
call me and asked me my opinion later
Sam was a coach I fail with my coach for
two or three years in Indiana yeah I had
some great Hall of Fame coaches if you
think about it dr. Jack Ramsey Hall of
Fame Larry Brown Hall of Fame Larry Bird
Hall of Fame Rick Carlisle will be Hall
of Fame Isiah Thomas Hall of Fame not
bad yeah well we just don't think of
Isiah Thomas is a great coach he was
good for us we had it was the transition
he came in after we went to the finals
versus the Lakers so he was from 2001
to 2003 and what we had just trade it
for Jemaine O'Neill we got al Harrington
we had Jonathan bender jamaal tinsley we
had traded full Ron Artest and Brad
Miller I believe his second season so
Carlisle benefited from all that because
he came in after Isaiah but Isaiah
Isaiah had us pretty locked we were
young King we should've beaten Jay if
you remember that was the series Jason
Kidd in New Jersey Nets were the number
one seed we were the number eight seed
back then it was the best of five series
double overtime game
yeah Game five in New Jersey we should
have beat them to move on eight beating
a1 we blew it
that was my last dunk ever if you
remember going down the way last
two-hander two-hander right thru hander
down the middle got Sal come on yeah so
I there was part of that uptick I know
Rick Carlisle benefited from that but I
there he was a good coach top three and
three pointers made rookie year Ray
Allen made 39% you made 35 percent Steph
Curry made 43 percent in your career you
were 39 and a half percent I'll round it
up to 40
Ray Allen 40 Steph is at 43 Kyle Korver
at 43 so those are the top five in
three-point percentage --is rookie year
and then career three-point percentages
so I don't know if you cared about that
or not hey by the way I got a new
favorite player oh my who no no you're
not gonna guess this IQ I can give you
50 guesses you're not gonna guess him
but he is shooting film 50 for the
threat at west ether where he's shooting
okay percent from the floor
forty percent from three-point range and
he's averaging over 20 points again I
would say
Nikola Yogesh no but I do like him he's
fun okay all right I'm on the right page
here and he's averaging over 20 CJ
McCollum no I like him to that this is a
guy who's no the Raider under the radar
shooting 52% shooting 42 from
three-point range and averaging over 20
in the Western Conference I would go
with a surprise team this year so missus
or it's going to be no other Clippers so
it's averaging 20 with those numbers
surprise team he's on the clip oh he's
on the Clippers well it can't be sweet
Lou to buy good call yeah 21 21 is in
line for a huge Davis yes he is and he
could strike gold and it's a the
Clippers are for real because I just did
the game last week and memorable eat
nothing was like who's the best team in
LA Lakers Clippers on like LeBron James
to tell so much yada-yada
Clippers are for real they are for they
can now could they win the West no but I
was healthy and they play the same way
so they make the play will the Clippers
play off oh yeah they're making the
playoffs my question is will they be top
four yeah they're making the playoff if
that's the case Doc Rivers is your coach
of the year coach of the year if he's
finishing the top four coach of the year
yeah
Reggie reg will be on the call with a
Kevin Harlan it'll be a Thursday night
it'll be the rockets and the Utah Jazz
great to check in with you again reg and
have fun on Thursday night the golden
boy
I truly appreciate
by Dennis I love you I will see it to
you guys soon thank you wrench for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]